with you know liberal people censor
people right-leaning people for the most
part there's room there's a quite a bit
of room for for disagreement within
their respective camps with wokism there
isn't and that was where I felt a lot of
pressure myself and felt pushed away by
them to answer the questions that I had
because I would maybe raise my hand and
go oh wait a second you know maybe open
borders doesn't sound like the best
solution to the problems we're talking
about here and you are chastised to hell
I mean it's it's crazy to to even the
the amount of pressure you feel to
completely be subservient to everything
that they say and to toe the line uh and
I can imagine that that pressure
can be a lot and it's a big weight for a
lot of people who would self-describe as
woke leftists and I think it has to be
personal for you to change your mind and
often that personal experience that
people have is being canceled or feeling
that pressure of having a dissident
opinion and maybe not being able to
verbalize it or when you verbalize it
going through the attacks that you feel
so I think that is part of how this this
falls apart but it's also going to fall
apart in just the chaos that we're
experiencing in cities it's unfortunate
that that doesn't happen uh however
until it hits the backyard of of
legislators in San Francisco we saw
mayor London breed go you know the crime
has gotten too crazy and we need to do
something about it and we need to
reinforce our police officers when she
was one of the the main pushers of the
deep on the police but it wasn't until
the crime hit her her side of town that
she had to say something about it and
that's the unfortunate part of all of
this you have to feel the failing
yes and another unfortunate part of it
is how racist it all is it's not you see
white liberals and they're not liberals
but let's just call them what they I
would identify as yeah
how racial epithets are ethnic
minorities for disagreeing with them and
you go I mean this isn't right is it and
everyone's like no this is what we do
now and you go well I don't know if I'm
on board with this
yeah the so I I said before the most
racism I've ever experienced was after
coming out as a conservative and I
cannot I cannot press that enough so I
grew up in a really small rural
conservative Town it was surrounded by
uh mainly white people was subscribed
completely to this idea of racism and
white people being inherently racist but
it never experienced an ounce an ounce
of it I come out as a conservative and
suddenly every single piece of racist
rhetoric that is typically uh ascribed
to conservatives was hurled at me I mean
I was called a house negro I was told
that I would always be seen as an n-word
no matter what I did I was told that I
was an Uncle Tom a [__] and of course
this is the same experience of Larry
Elder of Tom Saul of Candace Owens of
anybody who chooses to come out and say
these things if you want to really
experience or get as close to the Jim
Crow experience as possible be a black
person that comes out as a conservative
and it will you will you will experience
it I'm like can I ask you something
about like your earlier years because
you mentioned growing up in a in a
mostly white small conservative town uh
you said you're raised by the white side
of your family right so your your mother
is white she's raising you she had sex
with a black guy yeah like how how are
you then able in that situation to think
that you know all white people are
inherently racist when you've got a
white mum who who
who got together with a black guy and
who's raising a mixed-raised daughter
presumably she wasn't calling you the
n-word in your crib right right right no
my mom never called me the n-word
um so yeah my mom of course is uh she's
a white Ally but it's interesting when I
when I was working with all of these
white people including my mother at this
organization they feel so much white
guilt that they themselves feel there is
no way to sort of separate themselves
from from the history of white people
and although it might not uh take
take form as blatant racism towards
black people they may have black friends
they may marry a black person and half
biracial kids they still recognize
things like unconscious bias or say you
know that they can still be fall victim
to prejudice against people of color or
maybe have some internalized ideas
towards people of color so there's
always just a little kernel still left
there to be able to push the narrative
that white people are inherently racist
but what about you like you've got a
white mum and you believe that all white
people are inherent so your mum is
inherently racist yeah I mean I I can
tell you I didn't look into these ideas
too deeply
which is why they fell apart whenever I
was pressed on them I what is so
enticing about leftism is not only that
you don't have to look into the idea so
deeply but also you are safeguarded in
somewhat of a cultish manner that you
have no obligation to defend those ideas
and that in fact the the very Act of
trying to challenge somebody on those
beliefs is inactive racism is inactive
sexism so all I had to do was when
people were asking me questions about
this go oh you're racist just for asking
me that your sex is just for asking that
question and you're encouraged to make
those accusations and to not talk to
people who you disagree with
thank you